Rhonda sanctimonius is now using me
David pakman in one of his newest
campaign ads this was published over the
Fourth of July holiday this is an ad
that uh not only includes me but it
includes our friend Faron cousins from
Ring of Fire and many others the point
that the ad tries to make is that we on
the left were all scared of Ron DeSantis
what we're actually saying in the clips
that are used
is that we think DeSantis is more
dangerous than Trump to some degree
because he's less incompetent and that's
true it's actually not a terrible ad the
context is we all think DeSantis is nuts
take a listen to this and you will see
me pop up a number of times if Trump was
the original Terminator the Sanctus is
like the T-1000 Ron DeSantis is far more
dangerous than Donald Trump a more
disciplined extremist they're just like
oh well at least DeSantis isn't crazy
like Trump but I'm like no you should be
more scared of him than Trump she's more
Savvy he's more Coy and he doesn't have
the pitfalls that Donald Trump does the
real reason this man is so terrifying
is because he's managed to succeed in
areas where Trump has failed if anyone
out there thinks that somehow he is any
better than Donald Trump then they don't
know Ron DeSantis if you thought Donald
Trump was bad you got another thing um
he may actually be able to do a lot of
the things Trump merely wanted to do but
failed to do the Santa's actually knows
the system and I think Rhonda Sanchez is
far more dangerous than Donald Trump but
he's also more competent I think nearer
than Trump because he's not so
incompetent he's more cunning he's not
an incompetent administrator the way
that Trump was he would be more uh able
to get things done Ron DeSantis is far
more dangerous than Donald Trump far
more likely if he becomes president to
successfully Implement a lot of these
horrible and disastrous ideas now you'll
notice that when I mention horrible and
disastrous ideas they put the word
awesome on the screen with a little
asterisk so you know I saw a comment
about this ad
um that it's very creepy that they're
proud of this to a reason reasonable
person like if you just put aside party
affiliation
DeSantis seems like he's running for
dictator I read a number of comments
like this in response to my tweet about
this video but these are such weird
times that because the highest virtue is
triggering the left and triggering the
libs they actually get mileage
from so many people saying this guy is
dangerous for his authoritarian ideas I
saw another comment that said this ad
would be more effective if they left out
the parts where we're all calling
DeSantis dangerous like they they could
have gotten rid of all of those things
and the ad would actually be stronger
but it's almost like a badge of honor
that much of the country including folks
like me see DeSantis is incredibly
dangerous saw another response to this
ad which was along the lines of trying
to Pander to the right by bragging about
how much of a fascist you want to be is
a pretty bad strategy if you make it to
the general election and there's
actually a lot of insight there as I've
said before the way DeSantis is running
this campaign
is maybe useful in a Republican primary
and maybe not because he's making no
progress whatsoever against Trump still
pulling low 20s but the anti-woke stuff
the I'm a wannabe dictator stuff the
left thinks I'm dangerous stuff
it might play well in a Republican
primary and it might not but I don't see
any way that this is useful to DeSantis
in a general election now a couple
people wrote to me and said David you
should sue him for using you in the
video I have not consulted with an
intellectual property attorney on this
it seems pretty clear to me that if you
are a candidate for office and there are
people publicly commenting about your
candidacy for office that all of that
stuff is fair use that that's my
instinct I have no interest in suing I'm
more interested in the fact that he's
now using me in a campaign ad let me
know your thoughts make sure you are
subscribed to the YouTube channel as we
press forward uh towards two million
YouTube subscribers I believe we should
save the recording of today's show
because it's actually a pretty good show
I hope you'll stay with me I love a good
sauna after a workout after a stressful
or long day you get in the sauna to
unwind the blood vessels dilate your
heart rate goes up it can soothe muscles
and more now you can enjoy the same
effects from the comfort of your home
without a bunch of strangers walking
around which I personally am not big on
our sponsor Bon charge makes the world's
safest and most advanced sauna blanket
and it's tremendous I love getting in
there for reading or get a little work
done a little meditation take a nap just
gets you really relaxed super easy to
clean really compact lightweight design
simple to fold up and put away when
you're done with it and it comes with a
12 month warranty if you don't love it
returns are really easy no questions
asked go to boncharge.com
use the code Pacman for 15 off the link
is down below